this video is brought to you by raycon
i've never read berserk before but
kantara miura's sophomore outing in
golden age utterly broke me berserk's
golden age is a prequel story about how
the series main protagonist gutz became
the man he is in the present day
following him from his literal birth
until the lowest moments of his life in
essence this is guts's backstory and in
my opinion is easily the best origin
i've come across in recent memory in the
first part of this i explored what
turned out to be the upbeat section of
this tale as we observed the complex
relationships and dynamics organically
forming around the main cast of
characters suddenly experiencing a
fissure unlike anything i've seen before
in manga a fissure not driven by hatred
or anger but of ambition and hope advice
taken on board with the story in
question ending in one of the most
hopeless and horrifying places i think i
may ever read or see and what happens
between these two moments in time is one
of the best examples of character-driven
storytelling and character torture i've
seen put to paper and indeed one of the
greatest if not the greatest narrative
performance in all of manga that i've
read and i'm not afraid to say that
better than anything i've seen presented
by dragon ball hunter hunter jojo or
indeed one piece if you've ever
expressed an interest in learning how to
write compelling or exciting stories
with complex characters and motivations
berserk's 1997 climax to the golden age
arc is something to be studied
[Music]
in my attempt to split this mammoth of
an arc into two separate videos i
decided to conclude the first half here
but there is something to note however
while god swung his sword to end that
jewel it was not he who instigated that
outcome in many ways griffith's desires
from the beginning of the story all the
way to the end very much consumed him
and those around him and its guts after
having escaped from that metaphorical
vortex that throws off griffith's plan
to achieve his desires and it's here
that the positivity present in the main
plot's first half starts to drift
further and further away
speaking of someone that reviews anime
and manga for a living something i
routinely have to contend with is the
relentless amount of fan service in
these stories oftentimes i get it sex
sells and all but at the end of the day
to me it feels like a crutch or at the
very least an annoying distraction that
takes from what i'm really interested in
the story which is of course why i
watched keijo kintara miura on the other
hand is something of a savant when it
comes to writing these types of scenes
instead of feeling bored or annoyed by
tired and overdone tropes getting in the
way of the story i'm instead captivated
by these scenes as they not only enhance
the story but they are essential in
exposing us to integral and emotionally
revealing character differences
something that's abundantly clear in
berserk's golden age arc is that it's
centered around not just one character
or a group of characters necessarily but
a set of relationships and how they
contrast in subtle and stark fashion
with the two main relationships explored
after this jewel being guts and casca
and griffith and charlotte and what i
thought these scenes achieved perhaps
above all else was their highlighting of
the existing differences between guts
and griffith as well as their approach
to their respective encounters once
their deal concludes both guts and
griffith albeit at different times have
to face the consequences of their
actions griffith now has to face a
soul-crushing trip back to reality and
guts has to reconcile what became of his
friends after his decision in other
words both guts and griffith's
characters are exposed to a tremendous
amount of pressure and that's important
one of the most important techniques to
make use of as a writer is one that
allows you to communicate to your
audience who your characters are in a
believable fashion much the same as real
life someone's true character is only
revealed under pressure i've mentioned
this before but author professor and
story consultant robert mckee put it
best in his book entitled story true
character is revealed in the choices a
human being makes under pressure the
greater the pressure the deeper the
revelation the truer the choice to the
character's essential nature these
high-stakes high-pressure scenes are in
essence what turns otherwise boring
characters into fan favorites villains
heroes or otherwise take for example
disney's the lion king
alright okay i can see you all rolling
your eyes from here but really
techniques and storytelling are present
across all genres even ones as different
as berserk and the lion king in this
film simba is introduced as a headstrong
naive and in many ways arrogant kid
impatiently waiting for his time in the
sun as king of the pride lands to begin
at this point as an audience we have no
reason to care for him as a character
necessarily we appreciate he's a kid
he's cute and he has some great parents
but he's not proven himself to us and so
that's where this scene comes in the
elephant graveyard in this simba drags
his friend nala into a life or death
situation thanks to his own inability to
see the woods from the trees but in the
elephant graveyard despite being
terrified and in way over his head simba
still goes back to save nala against
those monsters he knows can kill him
this is the moment we as fans of the
lion king learn to respect and
appreciate simba's character and it's
one of the many reasons why the live
action remake fails in capturing that
same magic because they caught that
scene out of the film now we have no
reason to like simba and as a result the
film feels hollow and i labor that point
for one specific reason it's the very
technique miura's perfected the
technique that turned guts from a
character we appreciate to one we
despair hope and pray for in the end
following that crushing defeat during
his duel with guts griffith shaken to
his very core feeling like he's lost
control of everything in his life grabs
the nearest branch on his fall down to
reality and in a desperate attempt to
seize control of something he forces
himself onto princess charlotte in a
fashion never before seen by us in the
series it's incredibly uncomfortable but
it's also the most human this one time
god among men has ever appeared to us
even after the fact he feels hollow and
alone left holding himself distraught
it's an effective scene for all the
reasons i outlined but to add further
layers to this outcome as touched on
prior this scene is also a terrific
contrast that brings the best out of
what transpires between guts and casca
with griffith's relationship with
charlotte being born out of manipulation
leverage and ambition guts and caskets
develop naturally across the entire arc
he encounters her even before he does
griffith and i don't think there's a
single person guts himself interacts
with more in significant ways maybe judo
is a close candidate but even then
that's mostly light conversation unlike
griffith who sought out charlotte for
his own selfish desires after having
left for a long time guts returns into
casca's life not for personal indulgence
but instead to make a save in grand
fashion he learns of all the hardships
she's had to endure and how strong she's
been for everyone involved this is a far
cry from griffith scene with charlotte
and the differences only pile up as the
story progresses where griffith barely
spoke to charlotte even cutting her off
mid-sentence with an unsolicited kiss
gutz and casca work through the
remaining differences and baggage
together in one of the most beautifully
vulnerable and powerful scenes so far in
the story metaphorically laying
themselves bare before each other this
is what genuine connection looks like
and it's exactly what godz has been
looking for all story long and during
this waterfall scene there's a specific
moment where we as an audience finally
see the toll this past year has had on
casca's psych and we see the state the
band of the hawk has been reduced to and
from the deepest despair goths himself
helps to uplift her from this courageous
self-imposed prison and in no greater
contrast to griffith instead of forcing
himself on her he gently and slowly
comforts her naturally leading to their
first kiss it's a gorgeous marriage of
narrative competence and masterful
layout work right here if the story
ended i would have been happy but
it didn't
raycon are one of the leading brands and
awesome wireless earbuds offering
premium quality at a fraction of the
price personally i use their everyday
earbuds and i really do use them every
single day the thing is whenever i talk
to people about wireless earbuds they
recoil at the thought of having to deal
with bluetooth pairing and you know what
i can totally relate but these are super
simple to pair and have been a total
non-issue for me battery life is also
one of those things that wireless
skeptics are afraid of but since i
started using these earbuds i've only
ever had to charge them once thanks to
their 32 hour battery life they're also
super discreet raycon comes with a wide
selection of gel tips to ensure you get
the best fit for your own comfort but
also so they sit nicely in your ears
without sticking out but hey if you
don't believe me raycon offers a 45 day
money back guarantee so you can try them
out for yourselves all you need to pick
yourself up some of these awesome
earbuds is to head over to buy
raycon.com not mark where you'll get 15
off your order they've been a great
sponsor to work with and i hope you
enjoy their product as much as i do
the rescue of griffith courtesy of the
best the band of the hawk has to offer
is such a thrilling and anxious affair
there are so many different plot threads
dangling in the air with some
stupendously subtle paneling implemented
to foreshadow future events that i could
hardly contain myself throughout my
reading furthermore i really appreciate
how this ragtag team of rescuers are
incredibly proficient faced with
scenarios that are far more complex than
we've ever seen before i love how
everyone from guts to casket to judo to
even pippin find their means of
contribution towards this final effort
which will no doubt make what happens
after all the more shocking and
sorrowful again continuing to implement
the techniques spoken on prior miura
places our heroes in situations they've
never before seen the likes of having to
sneak into one of the darkest most
depressing environments we've
collectively encountered the band have
to make their way down to the cellar
where griffith has been kept all this
time as punishment for violating the
princess apart from the horrific imagery
on display during this segment something
that's particularly impressive i think
here was this page this is a wonderful
misdirection for the readers given the
kandor displayed by guts and the rest of
the band it seemed to me upon first read
through that this was a tender moment
displaying two friends reuniting and
showing their appreciation for each
other however upon closer inspection and
now armed with the knowledge of what's
to come we can notice that unlike guts
griffith wasn't crying and that he in
fact wasn't trying to hug him but was
trying to strangle him when we as people
are pushed to the brink our true nature
is presented and this remains true here
with griffith showing us exactly who he
is i think it's also kind of interesting
how as i mentioned in the previous video
guts's security blanket is in many ways
his sword and think there's an
interesting contrast here later in the
story griffith has a moment where he's
talking to himself about what he's done
for guts and the dangers he's put
himself in to protect him which made me
think guts was griffith's security
blanket and as soon as he lost him he
felt as if he had no control over the
world anymore like he lost a fundamental
part of himself in other words he was
put under pressure and he couldn't take
it in many ways the protagonist of this
story can only be as intellectually
fascinating or emotionally compelling as
the forces of antagonism make him in
other words a great hero can only be as
good as the forces of evil he's up
against and what i find so interesting
about that particular idea is the means
with which miura understood this rule
and chose to build upon it the strength
of a story like berserk is that it isn't
restrained by the limitations of other
manga narratives targeted towards
different demographics due to this fact
miura is free to make something look as
beautiful or as horrifying as he can
possibly imagine taking comparable
elements like these two sex scenes i
spoke on earlier making one of them
appear beautiful elegant and freeing
with this initial scene between guts and
casca showing us everything great that
can happen from an outing like this and
at the end of the arc some of the
absolute worst in a way berserk shows us
the very best and the absolute worst of
human nature and the story is all the
more powerful for it this allows him to
create those extreme pressures for
various characters i told you about
earlier and as a result makes her heroes
appear that much more legendary and
virtuous while making the antagonists
all the more underhanded and despicable
making for heavenly high highs and
soul-destroying lows berserk is a manga
of extremes with the arcs beginning
feeling extremely grounded but as the
story trudges onward the more
fantastical elements make themselves
known gradually over time this is all to
say that the characters of berserk and
the world of berserk serve to make this
one of the most emotionally resonant
stories out there if these techniques
i've illuminated were created to help
grab a viewer's attention then the
extremes berserk employee serves to
shackle the reader's attention to the
pages as they flutter by seamlessly
nosferatu zod and the battle of daldry
last week i neglected to speak on the
events of the battle of doldry for a
number of reasons i don't like to dwell
too much on heavy action set pieces as
they are a feast for the eyes but not
always for the mind with that taken into
consideration however the battle of
daldre gave me more than a little to
consider and sink my teeth into
particularly now that i've finished the
arc and have the benefit of hindsight
throughout this story guts has been a
man akin to hercules otherworldly
strength tenacious understanding and he
never seems to reach his limits this has
been helped on numerous occasions by the
circumstances he not only is placed in
but manages to crawl out of we've seen
him defeat monsters demons and even
armies of men all trying their very best
to take him down but none ever have
but one almost did
and it wasn't a monster or a demon or an
army it was a single man during gotz's
impressive physical display there is one
instance where for lack of a better term
or way of describing it he was supposed
to die that had it not been for one
specific character nosferatu zod guts
wouldn't be here zod makes his presence
felt numerous times throughout this arc
and always in a pivotal sense in a way
zod seems at the very least morbidly
interested in guts for what reason i
can't be certain but he is interested in
him nevertheless perhaps similar to how
hisoka treats many of the main cast
early on in hunter hunter
zod seems to be interested in preserving
the likes of guts for during the moment
he was about to die he threw him the
weapon he needed to survive at that
moment he was conflicting with our idea
of him as a character in our minds we
view him as the bad guy and now he's
preserving the life of the hero
character but knowing what i know now it
almost seems as though this was one of
the worst things he could have ever done
for this young man given his talk of the
eclipse which i will definitely speak on
in just a sec he seems to be involved in
this idea of preordained destiny he will
ensure that guts will make it to the
eclipse and once branded it's only a
matter of time before he guts will lose
his life in many ways zod not only
prolongs guts's life but ensures it down
a specific path that he's interested in
and it highlighted just how vulnerable
and human the character of guts actually
is
making his character that much more
effective
the eclipse it's going to be very
difficult for me to say something
concerning this aspect of the story
beyond what many before me already have
and to a much better degree i haven't
studied this act the same way many
people have and these are really just my
first impressions but personally i found
this to be a stunningly beautiful affair
in terms of artwork while also being one
of the most difficult sections of
storytelling i've ever and i mean this
sat through in my life and it's by
design while reading this i felt really
uncomfortable however in that same
breath i cheered guts on as much as i
could this eclipse had been an event
we've effectively been counting down
towards since it was first mentioned the
link was made with that weird necklace
egg thing griffith had and really i had
been waiting to see what sort of twisted
and sadistic circumstances griffith
would put guts through to create that
same level of hatred he demonstrated at
the end of the black swordsman arc and
by the way those of you that say the
black swordsman arc is unnecessary i
think are dead wrong the ark sets up the
lens through which we are expected to
see this arc going into golden age we
know how it's going to end and the arc
is written to cater to that viewpoint
specifically skipping black swordsmen is
in my opinion a significantly worsened
experience and certainly not
inconsequential going into this arc in
the back of my mind i was on the
defensive trying to prevent the story
from making me care about these
characters because i knew there was
going to come a moment where guts would
be alone and filled with the same
resentment and vengeance we previously
saw him with but i didn't succeed in
that venture because that's exactly what
this arc tricks you into doing it tricks
you into caring much like guts is as a
character we as an audience after black
swordsman have our guards up on alert
against the outcome we know is coming
but over the course of this sprawling
epic one after another our walls come
tumbling down as we learn to embrace and
hope for the future with guts and his
new team of friends we learn to love
pippin's good nature judo's sharp and
considerate thinking carcasses abrasive
antics casca's strength and compassion
and even maybe for a moment or two
griffith's determination like guts we
had our guard up against the evil that
we knew was coming and yet miura found a
way to help us warm to this at times
overwhelmingly cold world through this
lovable group the same way guts did
learning about their pain their
struggles and the sacrifices they've
been either forced to make or have been
apprehensively made when all other
options had been taken away from them
miura created a world populated it with
some of the most human characters we've
ever seen and in leveraging that which
we cared for he gave us exactly what
he'd made us hope never would manifest
he flooded this human world with demons
any sense of stability hope and
happiness that was once present is now
immediately extinguished in the most
excruciating of ways the pressures these
characters have been placed under has
been perhaps greater than any we've seen
during this we see who these people
really are for the better and for the
worse the term bad dream is mentioned
numerous times during this particular
apocalyptic scenario and i think it's as
if to reinforce the success of griffith
achieving his lifelong dream with it
effectively being everyone's collective
nightmare throughout berserk guts has
been depicted as a fallible flawed
troubled but immeasurably resilient
individual capable of feats of strength
and tenacity far greater than anyone
ever expected from him the trend
throughout the story has placed him
under tremendous pressure time and again
forcing him to place his life on the
line against impossible odds showing us
that he truly is a powerful heroic and
virtuous person reinforcing this idea
that as long as he's armed he's
practically invincible in combat and so
instead of continuing that trend miura
decides to subvert this very aspect of
him during the eclipse in this miura
asks the question what if guts can't
save them what if guts fails cast it
into a literal hellscape vortex of which
there is virtually no escape the
paneling once again is some of the best
in the industry but perhaps some of the
very best out of miura himself there's a
real sense of scale and horror to these
moments helping to emphasize some of the
more tender exchanges as the main group
slowly whittle away to nothing pippin
sendoff broke my heart as he stayed back
to hold them off only for us to see him
fall in the distance corkus 2 was
nightmarish to a horrifying degree but
judo's honestly took me by surprise and
because of that it hit me like a train
watching as he time and again does
everything in his limited power to
struggle and protect casca only two on
his deathbed revealed to us as readers
he in fact always had feelings for her
made me tear up beyond belief and with
everyone dead kaska captured and guts
struggling and crawling to her rescue
once again miura puts us and guts
through hell
for almost two entire chapters were
forced to watch powerless to do anything
as the person gots loves more than
anyone in the world endures some of the
worst abuse i've ever been able to see
or think of with the artwork capturing
how guts felt more accurately than i
ever could possibly describe thanks to
miura's masterful implementation of a
calligraphy brush hacking his arm off
and piercing his eye trying to get free
unable to change anything page after
page this kept on going relentlessly so
much so i had to step away from the
story after witnessing it but upon my
return a day or two later the worst part
came into focus for me for once the
eclipse came to a close griffith rose to
power as some sort of dark phoenix
satanic demigod and skull knight saved
both guts and casca the story and
torture in a sense continues
destiny there seems to be an interesting
push to empower the idea of destiny in
some shape or form within this story
time and again noteworthy events occur
as puck and gods without even knowing
each other indirectly intersect here's
an example early in the story judo tells
kaska about the elf he met in those days
when he was working with a traveling
entertainment troupe we of course know
who he's talking about but within this
conversation he gives kaska this elf or
fairy dust that ends up healing guts's
wounds after he managed to take out 100
men this link could have ended here as a
very nice cameo but later in the story
during the events of the eclipse we
actually get to see puck cross paths
with rickert so i wonder is this
relationship between guts and puck
destined to happen are their fates
intertwined in some sort of meaningful
way what is miura trying to tell me here
because we later see rickard meeting
with guts again and as it is said in
this troop scene he's going to be
important in later events there are some
other subtle details like god's crossing
paths with a count as he is the apostle
who ends up killing pippin during the
eclipse but this whole destiny concept
gets much more present towards the
conclusion of the arc where skull knight
and the demons tell guts explicitly that
he is branded and will be forever
haunted as a result and in this moment
guts fiercely declares war against his
own destiny as he believes he's the one
who blazes his own path even when the
circumstances point to everything other
than that being the reality which is
sort of ironic because guts is forced to
follow this path that seems to be
already decided by destiny he is healed
by the elf dust both zod and skull night
save his life in situations where he
should have died and most importantly he
crosses paths with griffith and griffith
specifically because it is said by both
humans and demons that he is someone
special and we see this at the end of
the eclipse guts falls into a pit that
seems bottomless while griffith rises
from the ashes like some sort of
primordial phoenix as he embraces his
true nature and his decisive victory in
this finale it's like griffith was
favored by destiny from the beginning
while guts wasn't griffith has
everything in his hands to achieve his
goals and dreams while guts has nothing
other than his sword griffith is allowed
to dream while guts
is cursed to struggle
the aftermath having been the only
person to survive that ordeal and come
out relatively unscathed guts
experiences the isolation and loneliness
that comes with the strength and
resilience he possesses for the duration
of this arc as things began to get
better and better for our main troop one
of my favorite aspects has to be the
relationship between guts and his team
but more specifically kaska their
relationship throughout was spectacular
and felt extremely real and as the
looming end came ever closer i couldn't
ignore that i knew what was going to
happen at the end of the black swordsman
arc i knew griffith would be someone he
hated more than anyone and i knew he was
alone and so as people died in grand but
horrific fashion i was faced with
something while gruesome was also
something i had anticipated a while back
on my twitter i shared some thoughts i
had regarding this series saying that i
wish that things would have stayed as
they were i tweeted this having been
convinced that casket would die at the
end of the story along with the rest of
them but in reality something at least
for now far worse has happened the worst
thing for guts wasn't for kaska
necessarily to die but for her to go on
in this tortured tortured state she's
left in and in learning how he has to
constantly keep finding a reason to live
and fight not only was beautiful but
tied once again back with that quote
griffith throughout towards the middle
of the arc guts now well he has a goal
to survive and to fight griffith body
and soul
before i go
numerous messages i received after i
announced i would be tackling this
series claimed that i would find its
contents too grim much the same as i did
with hunter hunter during my
read-through of that many of those that
messaged me said i would find more of
the same here and going into this series
i was very conscious of that being a
distinct possibility but what berserk
revealed to me wasn't unrelenting
depression but instead quite the
opposite behind the gore violence
torture and agony many in this story
have to endure resides a tale rich with
hope and love begging for someone any
one of us to just hold on that little
bit longer to keep fighting to keep
crawling to keep struggling towards a
brighter future it's one of the most
touching narratives i've ever had the
pleasure of reading and i can't
recommend this story to anyone out there
enough berserk's sophomore outing in the
golden age arc receives the highest
praise i think i can give a story i'm
excited to read it again
and again
and again if you haven't yet read it
consider yourself one of the lucky ones
because you have ahead of yourself the
possibility of enjoying something that i
think comes around only once in a
lifetime so if you can go grab yourself
the work of potentially the greatest
mangaka to have ever lived quintaro
miura and let's struggle through this
incredible tale of loss love despair and
happiness together as always i've been
told not mark thank you so much for
watching
so long
i'm waiting
so long
i'm waiting so long
i'm waiting
[Music]
you